Okay. How many of us are familiar with the Mango situation? Cuz
we can we can move on from this. We'll come back to it later
tonight. Anyway, I know he's being
weird. A Smash player. Yeah, he's a Smash player. No, that's
Smash. That's uh Is it Smash Ultimate? That's not Smash Melee.
Smash Melee players are not. Okay. Common misconception. That's
all of the Smash. Is it Smash Ultimate? Whatever the next Smash
is after. Okay. Not Brawl. Oh, yeah. Anyway, what did he do?
He He got very drunk. Okay, he got very very drunk at a smash
party that Ledwig was throwing with a bunch of streamers and
made an ass of himself. Okay,
we have a lot of different conduct that we could that we could
peruse. Okay, take a look at. All right. Um I think it would
be funniest to look at his conduct first. Okay. And then go after
to to look at some of the other stuff. Okay. Give me a second.
I don't think I've met him before. No, I've met a lot of Smash
people because
some of my friends that are in that circle, but I don't I don't
think I've met this guy before. All the parties I've been to
have been very normal. There's been no guys humping in the background
without a shirt on. Yeah. So, let's just uh let's watch real
quick.
Maya and Emily, we're not Mango on the
[__] end the stream. It will just be your painting.
Ruben donated $3. Hold on.
Feel like I am Maya.
Makes me feel like I am Maya. True. Oh my god. He keeps doing
it. It's just like why? It's pretty rough.
And the stream makes like did nobody in his like previous times
as being drunk and gone to parties not be like yo probably don't
do this and he didn't learn from that. Did nobody. Well, hold
on Kelly. We're getting way ahead of ourselves. Kelly, we're
getting way ahead of ourselves. I'm sorry. His shirt is off.
Do you He clearly has no shame. Yeah, it's feeling that way.
But why? I guess it's just I don't know how people managed to
I believe this is a cardboard cutout of him
is. And he puts that and then he's got that and he is humping
behind the cardboard cutout of himself.
Wait, should kids do drugs? Okay. All right. Okay. How long how
long how long has he been a famous
esports? Oh, he's been famous in esports for like uh probably
going on a decade, I would imagine. Like at least seven, eight
years. At what age did he first hit celebrity?
Was he Was he young when he first started? I think he was young.
I'm pretty sure he has not aged a single day from then. This
is like a child in a grown man's body. He's 33 and he started
playing competitively in 2007.
He won his first major at the age of 16. So he has actually been
playing almost 20 years. Way longer than I thought. He's 33.
He's 33. Yeah. He's 33 in this. Yes. Right now. Actively 33 years
old. Oh dear. I just don't know how this goes on for so long
cuz this doesn't seem like it was a new behavior
or b. It's like, did none of these people know him very well
and been to a party with him before to be like, oh, this is going
to be a problem because I just feel strange. Does he have a wife?
I do not believe so. This is cutie Cinderella or no. Vango is
doing it over here as well. I'm not. That's okay. Okay, I'm ready
to play.
The guy directed away for a half second. Vango just like spun
away and went back over to start humping the air in front of
these women again. Emily, stop it. You're doing great, Mango.
Very
Nice movement. Wow. So, this just kept going on uh throughout
I don't know how long this went on for, like in terms of hours.
He's now a person. This is a Lwig Lewig was doing, I think, Burio
Karts, which is like a drinking game you play with Mario Kart,
right? He was doing like Bureau Karts with a ton of streamers,
and Mango was one of the people there.
Why does every party with streamers look like the most depressing
thing to be at? I don't know. This should be fun. But yeah, there's
just a lot of people who are like antisocial, just sit on couches
only talking to the two people they know. No mixing of ideas,
no mixing of groups. It's just boring. It always just looks like
there is only one person having fun. And unfortunately for them,
this guy is like ending his career with this fun. So like he's
having fun, but apparently uh he is back. He's been back for
a little while. Yeah, he's back. Ruin the spark for me.
Uh, what? How do we Why do we pause
The stream die or why did the video go out? No, no, no. I don't
know why the video went out. There's a mirror. So, maybe the
Oh, he started Oh, it just it cut in bad back at the end. Hold
on. I'm curious how much this guy had to drink before he started
being this way. Uh, quite a bit. And we will go through it because
I think some of it is on stream. that
normalize cutting your friends off, especially when there's streams
Yeah, obviously. Do they all just let him or
uh to stop him? He has like a history of alcoholism and I would
say probably at some point if you're feeding alcohol to your
alcoholic friend, right?
Apparently, he's had some incidents in the past, too. Is he Was
he sober before this? Why even bring your alcoholic friend to
to a drinking game party? It's I don't know. I'm guessing Lwig
loves this guy because for as long as Ledwig's been involved
in Smash, Mango's been like the one of the top three or four
players in it in the game. So probably Ludwig like looks up to
this. I know Lwig encourages him. I haven't seen it yet. I haven't
seen those clips yet, but I am going to find it. Hold on. Boozley
deals with drunk mango. What is this
Don't say it. Imagine. Imagine. It's nothing crazy. Fooli like
pushing him down again and again.
There's really nothing. See, I think this is unacceptable that
he's like acting this way. But there are a lot of people here
who It's like they wouldn't want this, right? They wouldn't want
it. But it's not like he is I don't think he's like traumatizing
anybody. It's not good conduct. It shouldn't be supported. But
I think he's I think he's not traumatizing people. I think like
I think a lot of these people are like this is annoying, but
I don't know that you'd want him canceled over it. It is weird.
I just I don't know. This is one of those being canceled over
it is correct in my opinion. I don't know about being cancelled,
but don't say it's not traumatizing anybody. You don't know it.
Like one of these people can wake up like in two years and be
like, "Why did everyone just let that guy get drunk and be so
disrespectful and so like touchy and weird around me?" I would
say the Maya one. I feel like Oh, no. The Maya and Emily. Sorry,
I'm cutting you off. My bad. I feel like when you enable a creep
like this, um, when you actually
just let it keep happening and keep existing, you don't stop
it, it like you probably add to the harm that it's doing. Yeah.
I So, what I would like to see here, if you stop the dude and
cut him off and be like, "Nope, that's weird." Yes. What I would
like to see here is commitment from like the team he's on and
or the people who are like giving him alcohol like people around
him to go uh listen this was if you go to rehab we will potentially
work with you again if you want to if you want to turn that down
and not get help uh we are cutting you off like goodbye right
I would I would have liked to see so his team if this uh wasn't
clear the direction I was going I will pull up the tweet now
his team released him right after this shortly after this right
oh okay listen I was more so looking for
all of the people at that party to just admit that kind of a
piece of that he's kind of a piece of [__] No, that
they all are. No, stop focusing on him. I think all of the people
who understand that somebody is like a belligerent drunk or they
have problems with drinking. If you all are at a party and you're
like, "Yeah, it's fine. This guy drinks. Yeah, it's fine. This
guy's humping the air every couple of minutes. Yeah, it's fine.
This guy's like pushy with these people. We're all drunk. It's
all haha funny." Like, these are grown-ups, right? That's so
Oh, sure. that he wasn't stopped at all and Yeah. that it happened
at all. Yeah. I I don't think that these situations because other
people are there that it means that uh oh, it's all on this dude
to be I don't know, be better or remove himself from the situation.
I think it doesn't the the streaming element doesn't help. So
whereas girls might be able to be a bit more stern
and be able to move away easier in other situations, might be
less bothered by this conduct in a nonstream party when they
got their stream to worry about and all the girls seem to have
their own streams. It sort of creates more of an atmosphere where
they can't just as easily leave. So I don't know about traumatizing,
but it's got to be additionally unpleasant for this reason, right?
cuz you got to put it cuz all these girls are like nice girl
streamer quotations as well, right? They're not really the type
to say off you creep like I would, right? Is not like that. I
think cutie and Maya are usually like better at that. I think
uh maybe cutie. I don't think Mayer is the kind of you like I
don't think any of them are really super like it's a different
situation also when like cutie Cinderella used to just put on
like a character for stuff. I don't even know how much that counts,
but I don't think the other guy girls, right, they they have
like a um either way, they still got like a what's the word?
Um
keeping up their appearances for themselves and how they look.
So, it's just like additional dimensions to it, I suppose. I
just feel like stream is on, you can't even know if they're actually
enjoying themselves. They might just not want to
act like a victim in the moment. Yeah. They also probably don't
want to throw him under the bus. They probably don't want him
to have like suffered negatively from this, right? So, they got
to deal with like 10 different conflicting feelings whilst m
juggling their stream at the same time when there realistically
there should have been other people there to just deal with this
and there wasn't for some reason because there wasn't a single
person who could just not be drunk at this party. Why? I don't
know. Uh it looked like there were lots of people that weren't
drunk at the party. So, why did nobody do anything?
I don't know. Yeah, probably try not to vibes. Plus, it's like
weird to interact. Plus, they're streamers with no social skills.
I would say there's like multiple things going on here. I would
I would guess.
I would say it's not good, right? But I they just don't have
the social skill or whatever. They just don't have the balls
to go and like say, "Hey, you got to stop." Then they need people
there that can do that like non streamers or whatever just friends
or people that there's always people like behind the cameras
but a lot of these people have camera people or assistants and
stuff there are like you should make sure there's those types
of people at your parties it's not just a clown
even if you check to make sure like um everyone's there who can
handle what they what they need to for their own safety like
this dude does not have the body to be half naked uh you just
cut out cherry you just cut out half naked this dude this dude
does not have the body to be half naked at this party yet he
did anyway. Do you even if you try even if you try to like prepare
for all these situations bad things will probably end up happening
no matter
That's why after it's done you probably should like own up to
it. Does had Lewick taken any uh so responsibility? He did not
at first. Okay, he did not at first. He started his stream off
and this I believe was the start of the stream. This I I think
this was the start. I feel really bad about that. Talks about
it and you know I reached out
to anyone who I felt might have felt uncomfortable
u and talked to them. Uh I don't have Kelly's volume higher.
Cherry I was just typing to you that I was going to say you're
you're very quiet still. Um probably need you to turn up more
if you can in any way. Yeah. Yeah. I think I have Kelly at like
70% and Cherry at 200%. So yeah. I always feel like I'm so loud
on stream. Nope. This is good though. This is better. I have
the volume capped anyway. You guys won't have like massive differentiation.
Um you both kind of max it out anyway.
Okay. Anyway, we continue on with Lwig'sology here or talking
about and I already told Mango this. I'm no longer inviting Mango
to Mogul Boo's events cuz like you know it's a privilege to go
to an event, man. Like the whole point of an event is like it's
a fun thing to do. have a good ass time.
And if somebody appearing
jeopardizes somebody else having a good time, that just can't
be a thing.
Uh, now I see a lot of dialogue on like broader implications.
I have like I'm only worried about my team, my events. You know
what I'm saying? Like I don't speak for the melee community.
I'm not like uh
Yeah. No, he did get fired from Cloud9. Got kicked off Cloud9.
Okay. Um, but what I actually want to pull up here is Lewig talking
about it or not Lewig talking about it, Lewig basically having
a moment earlier in the stream apparently where he um where he's
actually like enabling Mango to drink. So, hold on here. Here's
the clip from earlier in the night. Hey, should we be feeding
Mango drinks, guys? Okay, Mango is like an alcoholic. Mango can
drink 30 beers and act the same he does off no beers. What? He's
a machine of a man. He said he had seven beers already today.
That's if you ask him how many beers he's had lifetime, he it's
probably above 10,000. So So basically people are like, "Should
this guy be that drunk?" Alcoholic means. What? Bro, every alcoholic
I know is just the exact same drunk as they are not drunk, guys.
It's the same. That's what alcoholism is.
This guy's an idiot. He's probably just I don't know imagining
what Mango is just drunk all of the time, right? That's all he's
saying. Like the default mode of Mango to Lewig is him drunk.
Yes, that is honestly what he's saying because he streams drunk
all the time and Lewig was not slowing him down and people are
like, "Wait, should this guy be hitting this far ahead of everyone?"
And he's like, "Yeah, this guy's good. This guy's good. I I don't
know how he comes out the next day." He's like, "I'm never inviting
this guy to a mogul moves event ever again." As if just throws
him under the bus. Okay,
you are championing and defending. Gross.
He's the champ. He's the two champion. He's never lost.
Valkyrie keeping it so real. Holy [__] Is this not
just enabling him? No, he's the twotime champion. We can't. He's
the twotime champion. We got a new guys. Mango just blew a 25.
This is so good. Oh no. Wait. Rewind. Oh no. Rewind to her reaction
right after she she said, "Aren't is that enabling him?" Oh,
right. Right.
He's Oh, is this event enabling? He's a two-time champion. He's
never lost right there. It's like she just stopped like, "Oh
no, he's I feel like that's what just happened in her mind as
soon as Lewig replied, oh no, Lewick's." And I don't know who's
doing this cheering, but it's literally like, "Look how [__]
awesome it is that Mango is this drunk right now."
That's why you don't put a drunk person in charge of the other
drunk people. It's like if you know you're going to be drinking
too, then dedicle
the looking after the party to someone not stupid. I don't know.
Hire some people to do that. You're literally saying that these
people are not adults. They need chaperones. Okay. Can Lwig's
mom come and chaperone this party? Like unironically, can we
get Lwig's mom in here? So like when you're drunk, right, you
should know that like you're not capable of really managing something
as effectively as when you're not drunk. So yeah, you don't even
have to be a child. You just have to have the acknowledgement
that if you're drinking, you're not as you're slightly incapacitated
at the very least, right? So you should have other people around
to keep an eye on things. I don't Yeah, but here's the problem.
None of these people are actually capable of doing anything themselves,
right? They just sit online and people throw money at them for
the most reasons. They are all mentally children. And when alcohol
gets mixed with that, they're just even more mentally ill children.
Yeah, you guys are never They will never feel like they are not
capable of doing anything. This is also This isn't really a
a like a a house party, okay? This is an event. He's called it
an event multiple times because it's an event. When you have
an event, you should have event managers and people that are
helping run and keep logistics of things. And it's also being
streamed, which should sort of further emphasize the fact that
this is an event, not just a bunch of people getting drunk in
their house. So, yes, it's not babysitters.
It's like event management. It's an Yes, you need that. No, it's
it really isn't. I mean, it really is. It's the same thing because
the consequences aren't just a teenager getting pregnant. It's
literally like careers being destroyed, thousands of dollars
being lost. But it's also just it's not even it's not even always
just that. When you're like managing an event, you're you're
keeping things running on time. You're making sure certain things
are happening properly. You're making sure people aren't stealing
things, breaking things. Let that you're not causing too much
noise. That's like an issue with like the building. There's like
a whole bunch of things that goes into like event management.
It's like some of my friends jobs, right? Okay. Let me ask. That's
kind of silly to say it's just babysitting. It's not babysitting.
Who do you think needs the manager? Do you think it's like, "Oh,
Lwick, get event managers because you need to minimize." But
do you think I feel like um
in from the outside this looks like Lewig wanted this dead and
he did it like in 4K and he looks terrible for it. But the only
person who loses is this Mango guy. I feel like Mango, if he
has this problem, it might have been better if he had his own
manager who will walk around with him, right? I mean, either
both could have explain to you the dynamic difference. Probably
do. Yes. But when you're with this going on here, looking after
your own event or Yes, because she No, finish finish. Go first.
I'm saying you go first.
And um when you're It's your event. You're the one in charge
of it. So, it's your responsibility to make sure these things
are going properly. And also, if you know that you're going to
have your decisions diminished by drinking alcohol because generally
speaking, if you are running an event, you shouldn't be getting
drunk at the event. You can maybe have a drink, but you should
generally be aware of what's going you shouldn't be getting wasted
at an event that you're running. It just doesn't end well. But
if you are going to do that, you should have other people in
place to make sure that you're not making these types of decisions
encouraging the other person to get well. He can't be if he's
sober making that decision, then he's even more stupid because
I assume that he's a bit drunk, too. So, he thinks that making
his other friend more drunk is funny because a sober person would,
you know, that that's a bit stupid, right?
I'm assuming he's drinking, too. He seems like he's drinking,
too. Guys, why does he seem like he's drinking? Maybe he is.
If he's yelling here, then yes, I'd agree. He seems like he's
drinking. But I the rest of it sounded like he was uh he was
when he was like explaining earlier that he wasn't enabling mango.
That sounded sober to me.
Thank you for the 14 months. Yes, Lwig was drunk, too. Well,
I mean, the chat said he was drunk. I I don't know if he's drunk
at that point where he was like talking about not enabling this
guy. Well, it would be worse if he wasn't. This sounds uh this
sounds like E smash though where he's like cheering. I don't
know how far apart this is or if it's far apart. Maybe at the
same time. And I it would have been nice to see him take a little
bit of responsibility for that. Be like, "Yeah, I probably shouldn't
got drunk at my own party that I'm running to make sure that
things don't fall apart." But yeah, and I'm guessing that so
what I was going to say earlier, I'm guessing that the clout
changes over time is what's actually causing the dynamic shift
because Lwig probably used to have a bunch of Smash friends who
were all old cuz every Smash player is old. Okay, every Smash
player is like even the young Smash players. Mango was a young
Smash player at one point, right? And he's 33 now. They're all
older people and they probably grew up like having these drinks,
having these streams. It was like not they might not even stream
these parties. They might just have them for fun, right? And
that's the vibe that they're both in. and he remembers his friend
getting drunk with him and having good times, right? And then
but they're now with a bunch of like 25 to 22y old 22 to 25 year
old streamers or a lot of them. Not all of them obviously Valkyrie,
Maya, Cutie are there, but there's a bunch of like younger streamers
there and they're not a part of like this vibe or that culture
of these people like getting drunk and making asses themselves
and that I think it's just like a major culture shift between
half of this party and them. Like it doesn't seem like a bunch
of the people sitting around the side are even drunk. Even drinking,
right? He doesn't remember that there weren't girls around during
those times. That's also probably true, AshersB. Yes. There's
a lot of like extremely male energy going on, right? Where like
if somebody's doing that at a mostly male party, that's fine.
Kind of. Okay. It's a different vibe. It's a different vibe.
It's a Oh my god. It is a different vibe. And it's always because
there's this one closeted gay dude that thinks it's like normal.
I just think people getting this drunk is usually a detriment
in general on a stream. It usually doesn't end well.
Yeah. No, that's probably true. At least that's how it was for
me in high school. There was always this one guy. He was closeted
and he always wanted every guy to do weird and he just acted
like, "Nope, this is normal. It's not like I'm uh with the girls
here. Like we're just boys." Okay, let me stop.
Live J at a party since he hasn't face revealed yet. Okay.
That is my go. Hey everybody,
Mango just bro 32.
Okay, this is like doing this. This is like a clip compilation.
Bro.3 is lifethreatening. It's like you can't be then unaware
of how drunk people are. Why would you think that's a good thing
if you're running
this stuff around? It's like people's computers and stuff. I'm
like there's no way feel smart at all. There's no way. You just
banned Mango from your events after doing this on the stream
after everybody sees this. How could you possibly get away with
that? Oh, actually, Mango just let's cheer everybody. Mango just
blew.32. Let's go.
It's like, brother. And then he's the next day he's like, "Listen,
we can't trust Mango at these events anymore. This is these these
events are a privilege.
And when you do something that makes other people unable to enjoy
their time. Just replay the beginning of that because it's actually
insane compared to this. Uh let me grab it really quickly.
So I feel really bad about that. And uh anyone who I felt might
have felt uncomfortable
u talk to them. But also, and I already told Mango this,
I'm no longer inviting Mango to Mogam Moves events. Uh
cuz like, you know, it's a privilege to go to an event, man.
Like the whole point of an event is like it's a fun thing to
do. Have a good time.
And if somebody I'm sorry, I would feel way too embarrassed to
go and do this. to have like myself clipped cheering this guy
on, feeding him more and more drinks, like getting him more and
more drunk and cheering every time he blows a higher and higher
blood alcohol. And then you go on stream the next day and you're
like, I'm not inviting this guy to events anymore. It's a privilege.
Listen, uh if you're ruining other people's fun, then then you
can't be there anymore, which is like maybe a good bar to have,
but not as you're cheering him on as he goes to like get drunk
enough to ruin everybody else's fun. It's up, bro. Lewig sounds
hung over. Ledwig probably was. Listen, apparently um I just
got linked a clip. Where is it? Here. Watch this. Drunk Mango
and Ludwig clip. Is that a Oh, this is from four years ago. Oh,
d I was bigger then. You're the drunkest. I'm way drunk. Look
at all you do is choke. Yeah, I go for chokes. Mango is not doing
well on this stream where they're reminiscing about a time where
they fought drunk. They I'm a grappler. I'm a grappler. That's
all you do. Mega only punches the pancreas. Look at these moves.
I'm better than you.
We are the worst fighters of all time. I'm wasted. I don't know
what your excuses are. I'm wast
men are so uninteresting. They're so unfunny. I've never been
this drunk in my life. I don't get it. Why? This is apparently
just how Mango operates most of the time. It's just his steady
state. Okay.
Mango Mango is actually convincing. Like listen, Lwig the the
up isn't Lwig thinking alcoholics just don't get drunk. The up
is al Lewig thought he ever saw sober mango. He just never once
saw sober mango in his entire life, dude. Hold on. Where's all
wasted? I don't know what your excuse is. I'm wasted, too. Let's
not pretend. You're not drunk. You're not as drunk as me. I will
never be as drunk as you. That's right. What's up? What's up?
Oh, this is their dynamic that they'd had for years just going
bad, right? Like I it feels so you throw him under the bus. I
feel like I don't understand how you could have a bro like this.
You encourage him to drink a whole bunch and then you don't show
up on stream the next day and go, "Guys, I need to take some
responsibility for my part in this." Like that you can't take
a little bit there with him. That's soed up that you could do
this for years. This is four years ago. And you don't actually
go and say, and the clip has to be from further back, you don't
go and say, "Listen guys, I up too. I was a part of this. You
need to judge me a little bit with mango. Okay, we're going to
fix this. I think it's because he has to genuinely see the the
behavior in a vacuum. The only way he could is to think that
that was completely unrelated to how drunk he was. But it seems
quite obvious from us. It's like it was a process, right? Him
getting to that point. And at any point, someone could have intervened
and done something and they didn't. And they just encouraged
it. And then there wasn't anyone there to sort of help deal with
the situation. It's just it just seems very dim. Yeah. And I'm
used to YouTubers having a bit more common sense when they are
this big to running their events and what they I I don't know.
Well, it's like you think about I know. Well, it's one of those
things where it's one of those things where it's again it's somebody
who runs a business. He's got a million-dollar business, but
he's not willing to invest the proper amount of money in his
events and [__] right? Like you do actually need
somebody there who's like basically a hall monitor. Okay. Like
a I Hey, you need a guy who's like I'm going to make sure that
I'm sober and looking up for your monetary interest the whole
night. Okay. Somebody's harassing someone else. I'm going to
take care of that. Yes. I I feel like I
I possibly upset the gays tonight. Might have upset the men.
I'm going to even it all out and say, isn't Ledwick's girlfriend
there? Does she not care that this is happening?
Judy Cinderella. Yeah. Yeah. What responsibility does she have
to, I don't know, see that her female friends are upset and she
knows the dude who's running the party and say something to him?
This is why we should hire people cuz then you don't have to
feel bad cuz you just
date. Isn't that why he's dating her? So that he doesn't have
to pay somebody to work for him. That sounds even worse. Uh,
no. I don't think I don't think that's true. Hire someone. This
is the actual job title. Event management. They're impartial.
They don't won't feel bad about telling your friend off for being
a freak because they're drunk cuz that's just their job. And
then everyone's happy.
Easy.
I think you had the exact wrong impulse there, Cherry, to like
cut off the misandry at all. We do a lot of misogyny here. A
lot of ironic misogyny. A little misandry isn't going to hurt
anybody. It's just not going to hurt anyone. People can deal
with it. Uh, Wombo Cominator, thank you for the nine months.
Let's go. Nine months on kick. Thank you. Thank you. No, the
Missandry is still there. I'm not cutting it off. I'm just letting
it be known. I hate everything and everyone. I think it's I think
it's pretty behavior that cutie doesn't say anything. What? The
whole party?
She frigid. Did she not say something to Lwick at the party?
I think she did. I think she said something to Lwood. Lewig.
And like the piece of garbage that he is, he probably told her,
"Shut up and go sit back on the couch. This is my party." And
then he did whatever the he wanted to do. And he's like, "Look
guys, this just blew a 2.3. Let's go." I feel like And now he's
doubting that there is one clip somewhere around here. Cuz realistically,
there are people concerned. I need the timeline on these clips,
too. I actually need the timeline on this first clip with like
when was this in the course of the night? Is this like very early
in the night? When is this in the course of the night that Valkyrie
goes, "Hey, this seems like a problem. Hey, we might be enabling
this guy. Hey, we might be enabling like a real problem here."
And Lwick just goes, "No, no, no, no. It's fine." Like, at what
point did somebody walk up to him and go, "Hey," he was like
humping the air behind extra Emily and Maya. Like, this probably
needs to stop. And he's like, "No, that's just him. He does that
[__] all the time. Because think about it. Are you
telling me when Ledwick goes on his stream and says, "Yeah, he's
not invited to any more parties that he's not aware of the piece
of that he was at the party and enabling it." Oh, I think he
is. I think I think he was thinking, "Okay, I can get him I can
get this I could get him all the way under the bus and we'll
be fine." And uh there is there was a poster. Hold on. There
is a post that I I didn't read yet, but this is from Mango No
Longer invited. This from the the big Lwig clip. So, some additional
info Ledwig mentioned later on. Mango did get cut off about an
hour before the stream ended, but it was too late. Lewig apologized
for egging his drinking on at earlier points. He will not be
making a main channel video out of this event, and he also may
not ever do a burial cart event again for a variety of reasons,
this being one of them. He basically said if one person at the
event has a bad time, it's a bad event. And he did reach out
to everyone he suspected did not enjoy themselves on the stream
to apologize for not having a handle on what was happening.
Um, okay. I mean, I I guess you'd have to go and watch more of
the stream to see exactly what he said about it, right? Because
I don't think I don't think if it wasn't clipped together, I
don't think his thoughts there where he like originally throws
Mango under the bus were I'm going to take some responsibility
here, too. I think that was kind of an afterthought at best.
But I I do want to see the rest of these cuz yeah, we got the
Valkyrie clip. I don't know why I went all the way back. I do
want to see the rest of the clips. There's still 30 seconds of
clips that we haven't seen yet. So, everybody
To be clear, that is dangerous. That's not good. That's That's
dangerous. Let's up those numbers.
Everybody get your second race ready to go. Wait, do
you Sorry. I thought you were Mango. I got Oh, [__]
me. You [__] me from behind. Get off me. Oh my god.
He's wrestling nicely. Wow. If there's only a way to know that
this guy could become sexually inappropriate with people. Damn.
Damn. But do you see what I mean? Men think it's funny to be
like towards each other. Yeah. Yes.
Totally fine if it was men on men. Yeah. If it was men on men,
nobody would nobody would have felt unc well people would have
felt uncomfortable, but they'd have kept it to themselves. Okay.
I'm telling you, if this is all guys here, if they don't try
to get some gender if they don't try to get gender parody at
this party, it's um it's all fine. Why is Mango when he gets
drunk to friends like this? Thankfully. What did you say, Kelly?
I do not have friends like this, thankfully. Is this the clip
we just watched? It's not. Oh, Jesus. Seven years ago, Mango
celebrating his birthday getting sloshed.
No, no, no. This is a pro. This is the type of who probably does
end up like a cat. There are some people that you have to you
have to like put barriers around them. Are you good? I don't
want to think about cats. No, that was I don't really Okay, there's
a very
in my town I do have a guy who cats. So, I'm just saying this
guy reminds me of that dude. I I don't believe you.
That would be in a newspaper. That would be in a newspaper. No,
it wasn't a newspaper cuz it's speculated because my friend heard
him through the door. So, she wasn't sure, but like it sounded
like he was like doing something with the cat. But this guy got
fired from like a restaurant that uh he was a chef at because
he was in the woman's bathroom and like there was a female in
there and she came out and complained so he lost his job. Um,
so he was like living at a it wasn't a frat house, but it was
like a house that was rented out by people going to college.
And he was like living there for like six years past graduating
cuz he's kind of just like, you know, mentally he was in the
mindset of being like a freshman in college and no one wanted
him and he lost everything and he was like listening to my friend
have sex through the room of her and her boyfriend
uh her boyfriend's room like in that house and she's pretty sure
that she like heard him with a cat while he was like outside
the door listening to her. Those that's
You know what? I don't even know if this story is making sense.
This did happen. Okay, I am okay. I can't confirm if he a cat,
but I'm telling you this sort of frat boy churish behavior.
These are the who end up a cat.
Uh against the cat's will, obviously the cat can't consent.
Okay. Churish. What? What is that? No, I said churish.
Yeah. What? What do you say? What is that? I don't know that.
No, I've never heard this word before. Rude, mean surely way.
Oh, Kelly was chirish earlier. I wasn't mean. No, we've already
gone over that. No, it means childish. It's just in a like goofy
like Ebonics accent kind of thing. Well, I thought that's what
you were getting at, but apparently churish is literally a word.
It seems churish to complain. quite literally wasn't mean earlier.
Why do you keep lying? All I said was, "Oh, you got one guy three
times in 10 minutes." And for some reason, he's taking this as
a mean-spirited attack. Uh, no, that one was trolling. That one
was actually trolling, Kelly.
we had that one. I thought Oh, hold on. When we went to the clip
site, there was a forcing clip. Forcen on Mango. This is What
is this going to be? Mango is getting cancelled. I mean, I never
like mango. Uh, like there's so much better fruit out there.
I'll be honest. Arguably, there isn't better fruit. What is his
problem with the fruit mango? Oh, karaoke.
I do not know. Hope he's doing well. Oh, the clip of his shirt
off. Apparently, everyone's just trying to run here. Mango comes
over. I'm down.
the touching the hair is not great.
Don't beat her ass. You guys are
I won't let him beat you up. Thank you, L. That was so fun. Thank
you for having
I didn't ask.
He's just obnoxious now. At least he's not horny anymore.
He's just obnoxious. What the hell is that?
Right. Borderlands spawns are actually good.
That Borderland spawns are good. It was fun. I was loving it.
I love Borderlands 4. I love to hear that. But this was the best
day ever. 10our
I'm salty. I could not go to I'm like very salty.
Yes, I am. Oh, to this event. Turns out we're staying here. Oh,
not to this event. No. Borderlands 4. I can't fly at the moment.
So, it sucks. Oh, rip. Unlucky. I literally went to TwitchCon
on a coach because I really wanted to go, but I could not like
fly. So, RIP. What is a coach? Uh, no. It's like bus. It's like
a bus, but it's like a specific kind of bus. Oh. Oh, okay. Okay.
Crazy.
Uh, she means Twitchcon Europe, by the way. Yeah, that wasn't
too obvious. Okay, so we see that Lwig has successfully gotten
Mango all the way under the bus. Hold on. I'm trying to see if
I got any other links here. Oh, there's a comment from Connor
on it as well. Uh, what was today? Oh, today Connor needs pants.
He's just like a politics. see how things go. I think loser.
I think you guys understand how I feel about it. Honestly, I
actually don't want Conor's opinion, especially if people don't
know who he is. I don't want his opinion. But this all culminates
today in Mango
being or banned from Twitch. I believe Mango is banned as of
today.
Well, I guess yeah, that is inappropriate behavior to other streamers.
Twitch partner Mango has been
Yeah, we we went over Tech's ban earlier today, guys. We'll go
I've got more content on it now because he's commented on it,
but uh we'll check out the Techone stuff as well. We'll check
it out. Second ban. Yes. I don't know. I think uh I just think
it's a little crazy as far as the the mango bang goes that like
Lwig's not culpable at all as Lwig's like cheering him on getting
drunk and LSF calling out Lwig for ignoring concerns he might
have been enabling Mango's alcoholism until it became a PR issue.
Yeah, this is fair. Lwig's POV. That's good, right? It does seem
like Lewig wanted to kill the Oh, I think I think it's the stream
afterwards that makes it seem like nope, let this guy die. Maybe
afterwards. Yeah. I don't know. Maybe like people didn't like
talk to him about how his he had attited to it. Because if he
was drunk, maybe his recollection of things is not like this.
But I mean, it should be by this point in time. I don't know.
It does seem like two people that are used to behaving this way
for a long time who haven't really been forced to
look at how that is maybe and how unhealthy that might be. I'm
not sure. Oh, well, it's uh it's not good. I just want to read
a couple comments here, right? Imagine calling someone your friend,
then throwing them under the bus and not even accepting responsibility
for encouraging their drinking. What a piece of
man. Some friend I think this is like probably the take. Yeah.
I I wanted to see if broadly like the public was taking this
take, right? This t literally he had people go up to him in the
party and like complain. People thinking that he's enabling norming
the party. He's telling uh he's pushing him away from like the
women hitting Emily throughout the party and he's fine the whole
time. He's fine. So, if you get
uh like a lot of external criticism for that party and for your
friend's behavior, shouldn't you fall on the sword with him like
you were doing the entire party? Yeah, you would think so. You
would think so. It's you're I feel like if anyone should be able
to pressure you, it should be your peers more than anything.
And the his peers did not pressure or did not make him feel pressured.
So, it's very disingenuous for him to, you know, have this take.
It totally is. Hold on. Is this the I want to see if this is
the same one. I'm trying to look cuz apparently he talks more
about it later. And uh Oh, okay. Oh, sorry. you have.
So, so I I guess my feeling is he's kind of compartmentalized
it that all of the other stuff doesn't matter. The only bit that
mattered was like the humping,
but he hasn't realized like the him humping him earlier in the
party or not discouraging any of that behavior and stuff before
he started doing it to other people. I don't know. I think he's
almost like, "Oh yeah, this completely drunk guy who's been behaving
inappropriately up until this point couldn't possibly do this
next." But then it's also the fact that he does does it multiple
times. I don't know how something can go on that often within
a part and no one does it. He doesn't I don't It's just baffling
to me. I don't know. I'm too confrontational to understand how
the things like this end up happening. Honestly, I'm shocked
other people aren't confrontational. I feel like you have to
be a very disagreeable person to be Emily and literally try to
convince all of the internet that no, I don't got to pay my parents
back. You I am rich. You I'm not paying them. Yes, that disagreeableness
only lasted shortlived time, but I feel like that dog is in her.
No, I Oh, it totally is. No, no, no. She is actually super disagreeable.
I guarantee you Extra Emily is uh her her like stream persona
is totally fake. Like, it's probably close to a 180 on how she
actually is. I don't think she's a huge I bet she's like actually
fun and funny off camera, but on on Well, people say she keeps
it up, but it's like clearly a persona. Like so much of it is
a persona. It absolutely I'm positive it is. And so when she
when she I feel like it cracks through. Yeah. I don't know. Anyway,
uh where are we going next? Bad about. No, this is the mango
no longer invited. God damn it. I wanted to see cuz apparently
Lwig comments later on as well. If somebody can find me a time
stamp from Ludwig's stream, I do want to just see if he like
comments on himself actually encouraging that he was drinking.
Can we watch the before and after? Because I feel like he starts
off in this clip saying like, "And for that, I'm sorry, blah
blah blah." Here's a funny time stamp from behind. Oh, get off
me. Oh my god, he so nicely. We saw this clip.
He thrust so nicely.
You invite the goat, you get
Rap two. You don't say. You don't say.
SA was in the lead. Unfortunately,
choked it. Mango ends first place. This is a no drinking lap.
Do you see this? He drank a zero.
Amazing. Hold on. Now we have to go We have to go look at his
actual stuff here and see what what's going on, right? We have
to go and see
is did he not stream his apology? Oh, he four hours ago. Well,
this is No, this is a different stream, right? That's a different
stream. Let me go see his burial cart recap. This is the stream.
Yeah, cuz this was days ago. This was like uh on the weekend,
right? What are we on Wednesday right now? This is on the weekend
that they would have had the tournament. And then so let's go
and see if we can find incur
mango. Also, what does what does the word go even mean? If you're
going to say that about that dude, why? It's like just throwing
the word away. It just doesn't mean anything. If just being good
at Mario Kart makes somebody the goat, everything else about
that dude looks pretty sad. He's also like kind of possibly the
goat Smash player as well. Okay, these are two video games that
do do not matter to me. Uh, okay. Do you hold people in high
status for being good at something? Lew does cuz Lew was actually
a bad Super Smash Bros. player who was not good enough at that
to be popular, but realized he was like attractive and could
just be a popular variety streamer, but he wishes he was a Smash
player. So he's best friends with like the best Smash player
ever because he wishes he could have been good at that game.
Yeah. So it's just sad. It doesn't make any logical sense, but
that that is what it is. Okay. Psychoanalyze.
Jesus. I promise you that that is going on sense. You're making
it just makes Lewick look sadder. Like nobody cares about the
Smash community, but he keeps like funding tournaments for it.
He keeps like buying tournaments. He keeps like running Smash.
He's run Smash by himself for like 3 years, hasn't he? Hasn't
he run Smash Melee by himself? like he's the only person who
like pays for tournaments and and he just does that because he
wishes he was good at Smash. He wishes he would have been able
to do something in Smash. This is like if somebody uh in their
late adulthood was still like a super huge fan of like a WWE
wrestler who like retired and was just like holding up events
so he could like hang out with that dude. Yes. Who's over here
calling this fat old WWE wrestler the goat. That's unironically
what this is. Yes. Yeah. It's like the exact same thing. Anyway,
this is where you start talking about mango. Now, this feels
really depressing. H well, we're gonna get what what the the
real goal is
talking about it, which was the bad of mass or excuse me, the
bad of burrio is the bad mango.
Yes. Yeah. 100%. 1,000% yes. So, okay. No accountability yet.
Let's see how long it takes to get to any amount of accountability.
If you guys don't know, there's a bunch of clips and I'm not
going to react to the clips cuz I mean, frankly, they're uncomfortable
to watch. But I wonder why he doesn't want to react to the clip.
Guys, we don't need to look at the clips. We don't need to see
them. They're really bad to watch. There's a bunch of clips yesterday
of Mango going around humping people. And I know this
uh uh cuz I I saw them all this morning. Uh and I also I think
was getting humped a lot myself. I'm also a victim. You think
I'm also I'm also a victim. He literally said that he was such
a gentle or something good thruster. Well, he might be implying
he doesn't remember totally, but also what would go along with
this is implying that he didn't really watch the clips, which
he just said they were bad, so he knows. He's he doesn't mean
apparently. He literally watched the clips. That's actually worse.
That's worse. He's the one. This is his goat. All right. He was
picking him up. He was egging him on and now he's like, "Okay,
I got to do the thing where I pretend like I don't remember anything
that happened. I was drunk and I need to be a victim." Oh, but
also he violated me too, you guys. There is also simply the fact
that if something bad happens at your event, you are responsible
for it. Remember when that girl broke her back at that event
at TwitchCon? Yeah. Who took responsibility for it? The company
that organized the event. When you're organizing the event, everything
that goes bad is your responsibility. That's the point. So to
not take any, it's just strange. Regardless of whether this was
his best friend or not, he's going to do this. Oh, hold on. Hold
on. I just want to make one quick point. The absolute worst part
of this for Lwig. I can already see it in his eyes based on how
he sounds right now. I guarantee you cutie Cinderella has argued
with him for years to stop inviting Mango to things. And now
he's getting in. Now Mango has gotten drunk and like humped some
of their friends and now he has to deal with that for the next
like six to 60 months in a row of like cutie being like remember
when I told you about Mango you didn't listen to me and now everything's
he he's yeah that's what he's looking he's staring down the barrel
of that. Okay. So he's got to very carefully execute throwing
Mango under the bus right now or else he is going to have to
deal with that for the rest of his life. Yeah. I don't think
it's going to be successful because uh as much as you do want
to hide behind the thing that you feel like, oh, it's so easy
for other people to just be like, oh, I was drunk. I didn't consent.
Um, you're kind of a for that because what were you drunkingly
telling him to not do it to other people? Was Ledwick super drunk
and just constantly telling him, "No, don't touch her. No, don't
hit her. Don't no don't hump this person. No, no, no, no." Oh,
true. He was kind of feels like he was aware and he had judgment
and he just he played into it when it wasn't physically like
touching anybody, right? That's true. Yeah. When he's when when
Mango's like touching Emily, Cherry's referring to when Mango's
touching the back of Emily's head is like, "Stop. You got to
stop." Like, "Please stop." He clearly wasn't too drunk to understand
that it was inappropriate. Yeah, exactly. You have to take you
have to take responsibility for if you're able to identify in
the moment it's irresponsible or it's uh it's like bad optics
or it's literally making her uncomfortable and she doesn't want
to say anything. If you can identify that in the m moment then
pretending you like don't really remember later is uhhuh not
cool. No makes you a weirdo. It is worse. Now I'm going to say
I don't mind when Mango humps me cuz I know Mango. It was super
weird if you watched any of the clips when he was humping people
he doesn't know very well. Uh, it was very weird. Uh, and yeah,
I feel like menace is like a cutesy term that we use with Mango.
And it's like, uh, it's like, nah, that's just harassment, bro.
You can't you you can't be cutesy about it. Someone else gave
him this lecture, didn't I? Uh,
he's like literally consulted with a PR firm before starting
this stream. I'm positive. Uh and so like look man I if you guys
ever listen to me after an event I'm pretty
consistent. I always say uh my main goal at any event is that
the people who are participating have a good time. Like that
is like number one the most important factor which determs a
good event. If people who show up have a good time. That's what
I care about man. And uh and I dropped the ball yesterday. I
mean, to be real, I dropped the ball cuz not only did people
not have a good time, some people had like an explicitly bad
time. Like, they were uncomfortable, wanted to leave early, needed
to leave early,
uh, cuz they were just feeling
Okay, that's some responsibility.
It's kind of What is this distinction? Like, yeah, I don't like
when people don't have a good time, but also this was like in
this case, they didn't just not have a good time. They actually
they had a bad time. I mean, I was just like so dramatic. It's
his way of I think so he doesn't want to just say like, "Oh,
people didn't comment." Because he I think he doesn't want to
get accused of like minimizing, right? So he's like he's like,
"Oh, I forgot I'm supposed to actually like make it work." Like
I'm supposed to go even further and say, "No, no, no. It's not
just that they didn't have a good time. They had a bad time actually."
And just that they didn't have a good time. They had a bad
It's not a distinction without a difference quite, but it's like
Do you think it's not minimizing it? to say, "Oh, they had a
bad time." Instead of saying they were harassed at my party.
Oh, sure. It is minimizing it in that way. But I don't I don't
think he Yeah, sure. It's trying to strike the right balance,
maybe. So, it is minimizing
Yeah, sure. Just saying what's actually happening, you know?
Uh, and that's like ultimately my my uh my fault, right? That's
on me. That's my event. That's my job to do that. So, so I feel
really bad about that and uh you know I reached out
to anyone who I felt might have felt uncomfortable
uh and talk to them but also and I already told Mango this. This
is where it gets the no longer inviting Mango to Mogul Moo's
events. Uh cuz like you know it's a privilege to go to an event
man. Like the whole point of an event is like it's a fun thing
to do. Have a good ass time
and if somebody appearing
jeopardizes somebody else having a good time that just can't
be a thing.
Uh now I see a lot of dialogue on like broader implications.
I have like I'm only worried about my team, my events. You know
what I'm saying? Like I don't speak for the Melee community.
This is him referring to Mango getting banned from Melee events
or getting banned from Twitch or getting banned from like kicked
out. I'm not like
Turnite. That's what I said last night discussing this off stream
with people. It's like listen, he's the only Falcon. You have
all Fox mains. He's the only Falco main, okay? He's like the
only one who's any good. Okay? There was another guy for a while.
That guy is not any good anymore. for I don't think but he's
like the only one now
uh
like championing any other action. I don't know how this wasn't
Lewick putting a hit on this guy. Lewig it how at this point
there is no excuse. He knows he is surrounded by the most sensitive
cancel culture streamers. He knows this. Yeah. He knows that
this mango dudeip drinks a lot. One second.
You know what I'm saying? The devil. The serpent tempts Mango
with drink and betrays him because that's just look at his reptile
eyes. It's funny that he's making the same point you're making.
Spitten. Yes. What is that? Me? No, it's not. Um,
but she's bitten or he? It's probably a he if they're giving
you money. You can't tell me that Lugwig doesn't know. All right.
This guy gets really drunk. He always humps me and I'm never
upset about it. Um, now I'm going to invite him to this drinking
party with a bunch of my friends who all actually monetize like
their victimhood on stream. That's probably a really that's that's
a really good way for me to put it that I don't mean that. That
was like Toya speaking through me. Um, if they have to, they
would though. Yeah, absolutely. Two hours on stream, but I'm
going to reset timers. Go. These people nice. These people are
not, we'll say, they're brave enough to um to be upset by other
people's behavior and they're brave enough to voice their concern
and their respect for themselves, which does very often result
in other people getting canceled or something like that, you
know. Yeah. If Bango up, this is not the crew that are going
to let him get away with it, right? Like if he and you are going
to get him drunk, he knows that around. Yeah, that's that's probably
another reason he's so aggressively pushing Mango out in front
right now. He knows that these people will start actually if
somebody makes the point to the people who are there like, "Wait,
didn't you guys like kind of point out to Lwig that like maybe
this was enabling the guy and maybe he was acting inappropriately?"
If somebody starts making that point within his friend group,
it's going to go from that to like, "Oh, Lwig might actually
be the person to blame here really quickly because the the thing
that I said before where it's like, no, actually just saying
they had a bad time uh feels minimizing
to me." It also feels like he's offiscating to the chat by before
he explains the behavior that Mango did that he first lets them
know, hey, he's done this to me and I'm okay with it, but I know
him and everything's cool. Now, I'm going to explain that he
did it to people he doesn't know. So, you know, that was like
a bad time, dude. It is like uh of course I wouldn't get mad.
I know him. Of humping people, you know, that's totally fine,
right? I know him. Wait, don't you know Extra Emily? Are you
saying you could hump extra Emily and it would be fine? No, no,
no. I I'm not the goat. I can't do that. I don't speak for the
melee community. I'm not like uh like championing other any other
action. I'm I'm just taking the action I can't take. You know
what I'm saying? And the action I can take is the events I control.
So, for my events, that's that's the game plan. I talked to Mango
and for what it's worth, he was very u like accountable. He was
like, I get it. you know, whatever you got to do. I I you know,
deserve it really. Cannonball. So, yeah. So, he gets it. Uh,
which is good. Uh, cuz it's definitely not a fun conversation
to have, especially hung over is thrown up, but but it's also
important to do it and important to do it quickly today cuz
like
I don't want this to impact M. You know exactly how that conversation
went with how Lewig just said it there, right? Like,
yeah, listen, man. I get it. You make a bunch of money doing
this. I know you got to throw me under the bus. It's okay. We're
bros. He gave him permission to strike him down, okay? That's
what That's what Mango did. He was like, "You know what? I know
you got to kill me right now to save yourself." And that's okay.
That's I give you Listen, I'll close my eyes for you. I'll face
the other direction, okay? Just make it quick. Just make it quick.
Master Baker. Like, I don't want to be at Master Baker and it
be awkward or weird. Uh now, you know, luckily I talked to everyone.
Everyone seems good. Uh it was more like, hey, it was weird.
It was uncomfortable. I didn't want to be there. Uh
you know, so so I think Master Baker is still going to be good.
That happened at 3 today.
So still doing that. Still probably going to go to adapts after
and watch the NBA finals.
But but that was the big that was a big T. What did he say? Adapt
or adapt? Because I feel is adapt a different. those two different
people. But Adept is really good friends with Cutie Cinderella.
Well, they call Adept Adapter, but I Adapt is a different person.
I would assume I'd assume he wouldn't announce that he was going
to Adepts to watch Faze Adapt. Yeah, Adept just doesn't have
the clout to hang out with Lwig. There's no way they mean Adept.
I'm positive. Yeah. And to watch the Who would just like signal
out I'm going to go watch the what? What was it? NBA Finals with
Adept with XC's X. Yeah. Not Lew or qualifiers. I don't know
what he just said they were watching, but something sports. Uh,
what would it be? Cuz I thought the NBA finals were over at this
point. He just said it. I didn't really pay attention though.
Yeah, I like rewind back like 10 seconds, right? Oh, you can
scroll there. Everyone Everyone seems good at 3 today. Watch
the NBA Finals. Oh, watch NBA. Probably going to go to Adapts
after and watch the NBA Finals. Was the finals ending, but but
that was the big that was a big T. What happened? There's a bunch
of clips. Uh but but the short of it is Mango was just harassing
uh a bunch of people at the event. That is that is the short.
Don't go to the long of it. Just go to the just you know
bullet points. Okay. The only relevant bullet point. Mango was
harassing a lot of people. Uh and it wasn't like I mean you could
see the clips. It it wasn't like uh with people he is familiar
enough like with a rapport to do that. You know what I'm saying?
Uh would you say it's important maybe important context to say
you were encouraging this person to lower their inhibition significantly
like so they might feel more comfortable doing that to people
they didn't know quite as well. Not even just that taking all
of the people who don't know him and telling them no this is
really cool this is really funny. Uh no no he's so good he's
so funny. Let's all clap guys. This guy's the goat. 32.32
blood alcohol. It is a tough one. But there's a reason I'm not
watching it. It's not a fun watch. I've seen them. It's a It's
a Ooh. So you guys, how do you even know? How do you know you're
apologizing for everything that you need to apologize for if
you're not going to watch? Well, he's saying he saw them. He
is. He's trying to say, "I saw them, but I'm not going to watch
them on stream cuz it's tough to watch." I think I know the exact
reason he's not going to watch those clips on stream is because
probably people go, "Wait, wait, wait. Watch this clip. Wait,
wait, wait. Oh, you're taking clips. Let's watch this
It's out there. It's easy to find. It's a hard watch for sure.
The PR and I apologize without context. I get it. I get it. Guess,
you know, some people I see are like, "Why'd you even invite
him in the first place?" This is our third burial card event.
You know, like we've done this twice before with Mango both times.
Uh
I want clips or videos from the previous burial card events.
I feel like Mango did some weird at these previous events. I'm
almost positive.
No, there's no way. There's no way he's using that as an excuse.
Like, come on, you guys. This is the fifth party I threw. Nobody
got at the past four. How could I have foreseen this? I That
is the excuse. Yes, that's the excuse he's using. Listen, we
had no We had no way of knowing. We had no way of knowing he
was like this. How could you be mad at me, dude? I had a perfect
reputation before this. What the [__] How was I supposed
to I don't know. It just happened out of nowhere. And it wasn't
a problem.
So, that that was my expectation going into this. And I only
think I was actually there for like one interaction with Emily
where Mango was like being in my in my thought in the moment
too touchy. So I I put a stop to that but I didn't really Oh.
Do we have to watch that clip again? He just says he put a stop
to it. I feel like Mango like drumed on her head for like 30
seconds.
They were like, "Hey, stop." And then Mango walks back and like
keeps drumming on his head. Yeah. Yeah. It's like he keeps drumming
on her head over and over again. Hold on. Where the where the
is this top? Hold on. All he did was put batteries into a humping
machine. Kind of muad. Let me see here.
Where's the is the Emily stuff at the end? No, no, no. Where's
the Where's the Lwig Emily clip? God damn it. It was here. Lwig.
Ledwig. Lewig. Yeah, this is it. This is it. Extra Emily. Right
here. This is the one. This one's gone. I need the mirror. God
damn it. Hold on. Getting the mirror. I saw you saying her name.
I imagine you saying it racist for some reason. Actually,
I would never karaoke.
I would never. Just did. Well, apparently. What do you mean I
just did? You did. You You just said it. Okay. Trying to run
it here cuz you got I drinks and it's easy to set up. You You
just heard him say it right there. Emily, it was him. Oh, [__]
It was It was not him. I'm gaslighting you really badly. I'm
sorry. I said it racist the first time, too. I don't know if
you're joking now. I don't know if you're joking now. I did say
extra MO.
No, I actually I knew that you said it. I thought you were just
trying to be funny and I just sort of felt bad for you so I went
a long way. Sounded like a speech impediment.
What are you touching? Don't pull her hair. You guys are amazing.
Don't beat her ass up. Pushes him away. Thank you. I won't let
him beat you up. That was so fun. Thank you for having me. I
did ask your final. Thank god Lwig shut this down. Thank god
Lwig put an end to this. I got second in the in the worst cup
in the silver cup.
Right. Borderlands. Oh, he's coming back. Was that Borderlands
good? It was fun. I was loving it. I love Borderlands 4. I love
to hear that. But this was the best day ever. 10our stream.
Surely he's boxed out now. He's boxing out. He's boxing out.
You only watch that [__] once. Yes, I am. Uh, turns
out we're staying here. Okay, we're going to do karaoke on this
TV over here. Okay, let's do it. Oh, the box was effective. Okay,
the eventual box out was effective there. She deaf, snitched,
and complained. I don't think so. I think Maya was the one. So,
somebody said this earlier, and I'm not like calling Mia out
for doing this. It's your right to do it if somebody comes over
and humps your head, but Maya was the person who looked real
about it to me. Like Maya did not look happy at all. Do you think
what was racist?
The when the white guy went up to her and like it looks like
he just decided for her. We're going to stay and do karaoke.
Like he automatically assumed that because she's Asian she wants
to stay and do karaoke. Oh yeah. I have no idea. No, not for
that. I thought you were saying like it was her white boyfriend
and he just assumed she's like a submissive or staying actually
and doing karaoke and she's just going to listen. He didn't ask
can we stay do to karaoke. Just said we're staying karaoke. Yeah.
And after some guy is just like hitting her on the head. By the
way, we're staying. Okay. I guarantee Mango didn't get get close
either get close to Maya in the past bureau car parties or she
wasn't there. Oh no no. That Tom Bronson just said the past bureau
car parties were sausage pests which is unfortunately probably
why this behavior just didn't go went like under. Really? How
are all of the up things that I say? How are they just right?
Men are so to each other. They Yes. Yeah. It's a dominance thing
obviously guys. Yeah we're not but mango on the other hand.
Yeah, Maya does not seem like Maya Maya does not seem like she's
playing. Okay, Emily seems like she could roll with this. It's
hard to say whether it's the character or whether she like actually
could roll with this. I lean towards Emily being the person
got to go stream, but if this stuff happened off camera, Mango
would still be coming to the next Lewig. Sad. Also, how can he
drum? Okay, thank you for the donation, Toya. Good luck on your
stream. Um,
okay. What was I? Oh, Maya does not seem happy. Emily, I could
see Emily being like in character or this could be like her being
in character and like letting it slide but her being okay with
it or possibly just being like non-combative and letting it slide.
Either one. But I lean towards her like not really caring because
she is the person after all who wrote the Excel spreadsheet
of
Okay. describing size, length, uh, stroke of all the dudes she'd
ever Right. She's the person who keeps the spreadsheet. Yeah,
that's her. So, I tend to think that she's like probably not
super offended by stuff like this. Okay. No, but I think um you
don't have to be super offended to support like one of your friends
being offended.
Yeah, that that's the thing. That is what it is is like if everybody's
okay. It's mostly also that Maya is clearly not okay with this
and Mango comes back, right? If somebody were to make a mistake
and they can like sense the vibe, they're not like super drunk
off their ass and they can sense the vibe, then I I tend not
to like want to punish that person, right? They're like, "Oh,
I I up." But if they're like explicitly like they up the vibe
and then they keep going, it's like, "Yeah, you actually
he comes back after she was not happy. He's pumping toad." No,
no, no. End the
End it.
Mango says, "End the stream." She is. Yeah. I'm sorry. Maya is
not cool with this at all. Oh. And then there's some dude who
just keeps walking around and seeing this hitting people and
helping. He's like, "Hey, you want to do karaoke? I see what's
going on right now, but like karaoke. Are you down? Is wrong
with the people at this party?" Maybe he just loves karaoke.
I can relate.
Yeah, I do too. Who doesn't like karaoke? Just a goal. Probably.
He doesn't know any songs. Probably. I love karaoke. No, you're
wrong. I love
Are you karaoke? Yes, I am. Uh, turns out we're staying here.
We're going to do karaoke on this TV over here. Yeah. Yeah, let's
do it. Okay. I don't know if that's her boyfriend, by the way.
I have no idea. I said I don't know. I don't know if other people
are just filling that in or what. I don't think she's stupid
enough to have a boyfriend. Like, she's a savvy businesswoman.
She would never openly have a boyfriend as a streamer, right?
Or is that me just looking at her and thinking you're as I don't
know?
I have no idea. I just kind I see her as Amaranth without the
actual like on the bed. I see her as Amaranth. Okay. Amaranth
has a husband though. Amaran. Okay. Let's see
or something with Nickley's Asian hardworkingness. Okay. She's
like fusion of them together. What do you mean hardworkingness?
Nick Lee, his hard work was to buy expensive watches. Shut up,
Nick. Tell his wife to work hard. Okay, it is so easy for men
to just look at other men and be like, "Yeah, that guy works
hard cuz he spent his wife's money." Nick's ability to tell his
wife she needs to work hard. Okay, listen. That was very difficult.
Okay, he had to train a white woman from a trailer park on how
to not be lazy. That is so impressive. That's like teaching a
dog how to do arithmetic. Okay. Was she from a trailer park or
did you just add that in for flavor? I thought you told me that.
No. Stop blaming me for your gossip.
By the way, I like Amaranth. That's It's jokes. It's jokes. Just
so we're clear. Jokes. I respect I think she made a calculated
move not telling people that she had like a partner. I don't
know why I just like assume that Emily probably would do the
same. Just like avoid having a boyfriend while you're like this
female streamer on top. Well, I think that is broadly the way
to make more money. Also,
I've done I don't think so, we're watching this Lewig thing.
I don't think I've heard him actually say like, "Oh, I have some
responsibility here yet." Right? We're like eight, nine, we're
sorry, seven minutes in. And I still haven't heard him say people
said later on he comments and says that like, "Oh, some of it's
my fault, too." But I don't think we've seen that yet.
Yeah. So, sorry. We do need to keep watching. Yes. really like,
you know, I was too locked in, I think, on like running the event,
commentating, playing to like keep track of that. And, you know,
this is also
I saw some other complaints about Brio in the uh the production
quality. We're a way smaller team now, y'all. We are way way
smaller team now. Uh this is not off-brand. Give me two seconds.
I'll be right back. events, productions where that lock and key
like we have a dozen total people staffed.
Uh so I mean the advantage is
last year bio cost $75,000 and you know we had 30 people running
it. This year it cost $15,000
and we had five people running it. How did that cost $15,000?
Um did he buy new computers for this? Where's his overhead cost
coming from? He's saying that there were people running it. Where
were the
A dozen people? Are you just hiring your friends that get drunk
at the party? What are you talking about? I think he must mean
that there were people who set up beforehand and then people
who cleaned afterwards. He had Well, no, no, no. He had So, probably
beer for whatever like 50 people or something would already be
what, three to 5k. Why? Depends on what they get. Yeah. No, no,
way overshot. Wait, we overshot that. We overshot that. We overshot
that. We overshot a single single keg for like three kegs tops.
Yes, that is like three kegs top. I don't know why I overshot
tops. I don't know why I overshot that so badly. Okay. Well,
he should only No, for that many people for as drunk as people
should get. It should be one keg. You should not get You shouldn't
even tap the keg out for this many. They need a whole keg just
for They needed a whole keg just for mango. Okay. And that's
how you would know this drank too much. We went through an entire
keg already.
I'm British. We don't use kegs. I'm like, okay. What do you mean,
Cherry is such a bummer? You got We're all watching that this
guy got too belligerent drunk at this party. I do think that
these people needed some sort of limit. I don't know. Mind you,
I'm just going I'm just going off of how much of a keg I've used
like in high school.
Like one keg was enough for like 20 high schoolers. I quite literally
don't drink. So, brew.
Um, so there'd be beer, there'd be they need to get like the
consoles or whatever. They need to get the the I I I don't see
how they get quite to 15K, but then also paying people to market,
paying people to do graphics. They do like graphics and they
do like setups and planning for the event, too. So, there would
have been like pre-planning for the event. it wouldn't have been
it wouldn't have come through in the production as much there,
but like they probably would have had like, you know, bracket
graphics for their stream showing like people progressing through
the tournament or something, right? Like I think I I understand
that they could spend 5 to 10kish
and then they're probably overpaying. They might be paying like
double what you would expect if you're doing it on like a shoestring
Like realistically, I don't know if you know the story behind
um off-brand events, Cherry, but Lewig basically was getting
stolen from as they ran massive streaming events for people and
he makes so much money from his YouTube channel and that he didn't
even notice. It was like a rounding error on his he didn't even
notice that they were stealing like hundreds of thousands of
dollars from him. Yeah. I think all of these people just tried
to find like loopholes in how to keep the most of their streaming
revenue.
So they have like these other companies, other uh events and
stuff like that to do tax write offs. So I actually don't believe
people like Lewick when they say, "Oh, this event costs this
much money. This event costs this much money. I had to hire this
many people for this event. Uh nice try. I don't buy it." I think
yeah, probably like paying people
like obviously he's not keeping the money, but he is like spending
it on clout to pay these people to like work for him and say
nice things about him and stuff. Like it's Yeah. spreading it
around. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Do you agree with those write-off ideas?
I don't think you save money by doing tax write-offs. I think
you basically can spend this money. It's not your income anymore,
but you could spend it giving it to other people and get like
more distance out of it than you could by just spending it on
or investing it or whatever, right? Like he he tries to build
communities and like build his own like cloud up, right? I think
that's how I feel like I feel like when you get into streaming
when you start making a lot of money, you see how much of it
goes to taxes. And so if you feel like, okay, I would have to
pay this in taxes anyway or I could find a way to write this
off and like hire some friends. And I think that's what ends
up happening. Yeah. Exactly. Yep. Yeah. But I I don't know to
then use that as like, oh, look, I'm this good person. And I
do this and I do that and oh look how much money I used here
then. Okay, shut the [__] up. You know why you're
doing it. Yeah, I And dude, I I agree. I'm annoyed that somebody
implied that like uh the tax write off thing was the only idea
there. Sorry. Oh, what what else is it? Explain. No. Uh no, I
just nothing. It's a chat message. I'm I'm not going to I'm not
going to get one guy or you get mad. I'm just going to hit play
on the video. It's not important. I don't get mad. That's going
to be a little I'm interested. I never get mad at you getting
one guy going. I just make fun of it because you get mad. Well,
when it's me specifically. Okay. I never get mad. Why would I
get mad? Stance also ignores concerns about Mango and says, "What
is Bro, Mango? Mango, give Mango water." Bro, I gave him the
beer.
Yeah. I don't know, bro. No, dude. Can we zoom in on that? S
is the worst person. No, I've seen May. I'm sorry about this.
That's right. That is That is Oh, yeah. He hasn't. That is very
true. This is his pe no. This is like stage two. Honestly, this
is sober. He's not fighting anyone. He's trying to fight me.
Yeah. Well, that's fair. He's Listen, S. It's not that big a
deal, SA. It's not that big a deal. He is like
Listen, if you were to describe him in a legal document, Pisco
wouldn't be mad if you described him as obliterated. Okay. Pisco
would actually be like, "No, no, no. That is the legally required
term at this point." No. No, no, no, no. This is like stage two.
Honestly, this is sober. He's not fighting anyone. He's trying
to Although, technically, he is standing on a swivel chair and
not losing his balance. So, how I don't know. Okay, how far into
the stream is this? Because I do feel like uh Sinnette telling
people to give him water makes sense. And if after Lewig is announcing
his blood alcohol level, there are other people who's like, "Yeah,
give him another beer." Honest do something. Um, yeah, I think
it's after that because he now has no clothes on at all. It's
not just no shirt. He doesn't have pants on either. Those are
his underwear. So, yeah. Where are those public apologies? I
Yeah, I don't know. I don't know. I'm sorry that I actually thought
that it was funny and I know this guy was drunk and probably
needed help making better decisions and I chose to give him another
beer instead knowing that he was uh in a really bad place. Yeah.
I don't know where those people are. I'm I keep hoping that Lwig
is eventually going to get there. Yeah, I keep hoping Lwig is
going to get there, but he just keeps not quite getting there.
Little different. Now, having said that, uh still no excuse for
the like I don't know what you call it, like comfortability
like that shouldn't be jeopardized. And I don't think necessarily
uh
was because we were shorter staffed. But but anyway, I short
staffed in like the long-term thinking department for sure. Like
there wasn't a single person there who was like, "Oh, I have
to step in and fix this right now." Uh that's it. That's the
big sort of like
ugly we got to talk about. Thank you, Will. Appreciate that.
If you're somewhere where there's alcohol, you got to accept
some wacky might go down, especially at a quote unquote house
party. Uh, this is literally a streamer party run by a millionaire
streamer with tens of cameras there like streaming the whole
thing. I don't think you would have to just accept that some
people are going to get humped. I think that's an
ridiculous thing to That's just an absurd thing to say. Ever
heard of Diddy? Oh, did D did Diddy invite a whole bunch of people
to bring their cameras in and record every every element of his
party from every possible angle? Is that what Diddy did? No,
actually what Diddy did was after people found out about those
parties, he decided, "All right, I need to get on the yacht with
a bunch of women. Give me your phones. Y'all ain't taking any
phone on this boat right now." Like, and I don't think we've
ever heard back from those women. I don't know who those women
were. I don't think they're okay. I am unfamiliar with I I'm
familiar with they took people out on a boat like after the allegations
dropped and took their phones. They're in uh they're Listen,
Diddy probably bought the Epstein island. Okay. They're just
staying there now. But that's just to make your point like uh
phones got taken away. They weren't allowed to record. Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. Um Frank says the correct answer here. Okay. He
has the correct answer. I'd say it's like a work party. You shouldn't
be acting. Yes, it is like a work party where you can get drunk
and you can have a good time, but oh my god, you cannot let things
go like that far overboard. Okay, you can't. They people want
to say women aren't dumb. Allegations drop and they still go
in a boat. Okay, that is [__] That's fair. It's actually
fair. That is not a good not a good look for women. Okay, this
guy has the allegations drop against him. All of the Diddy party
allegations and you get on the boat with him and drive off into
the ocean. You give up your phone and then you get on the boat.
I'm sorry. That's not a good look for women broadly. Okay, stop
it. Those aren't just women, okay? They're prostitutes. Okay.
I thought you were going to say something about men getting on
and giving up their phones, too. But okay. All right. I'm just
saying it's it's not gendered, right? I think prostitutes just
overall might make really bad decisions because they need money.
Much like male Twitch streamers.
True. True. Speaking of guys, if you want more time on the stream,
okay, you need to donate money. Give me money cuz I am desperate
for it. Okay guys, if you like this, if you like the content,
you can sub on kick. You can TTS through Streamlabs or Kickbot.
All right, exclamation point donate in the chat will give you
both of those links. Um the the Kickbot link is $2 minimum. The
Streamlabs link is a $3 minimum, I believe. Okay, exclamation
point donate in the chat did not work. I'm going to try it again
one more time. It Okay, there's the Kickbot link. Thank god one
of them worked so I can pin that in the chat. Thank you. Thank
you. All right. Not all these are not the only ways to monetize.
You can also sub on Twitch with your primer. You can give subs
on kick on Twitch as well. If you only sub one place, sub on
kick because the split is 955 instead of 50/50. Okay? It's way
better on kick. Last but not least, guys, there's a patreon.
If we don't make it past six hours tonight, we'll probably do
an oiler call. Okay? I'm interested in doing an oil call. I've
got stuff I kind of want to do. Okay? Patreon.com/jsdk.
Couple different tiers. or the call is pre-stream, post stream
content. JWDP $100 tier, you get a unique color in the Discord
and you just support a whole bunch. Okay, we love everybody who
signed up for the the Patreon. All right, $5 tier, you get uh
soundboards, you get access to Discord during like stream intros
and stuff when I shut it down. Okay, it's awesome. You see a
bunch of Diddy's chargers are getting dropped. Nope. Also, if
you guys um you guys are hate watching or if you're watching
this because there's not a market replacement for a J-ST, you
don't like his Ethan takes and you feel like he should feel the
repercussion of those Ethan takes, you can uh choose to just
go to my Twitch account and just donate to me and don't do it
to him. And I promise I will not share any of that revenue with
him. And if you like, include that you would like me to show
him that you actually went out of your way to donate to me. Thank
you. What the [__] is doing, bro?
Uh, a lot of people reached out who went to the event who had
a good time, which is good. So, I know some people had a good
time, but like one person has a bad time. It's a failed event
in my mind. So, I mean, to be honest, I don't think we're I don't
think we're making a YouTube video of this event now. Like, I
think I'll just throw it on Lwin. I think it would just be hard
to do it in a way that's not agon, you know what I
Well, I think they'd have to cut out a lot of the scenes of him
enabling Mango. Okay, between him enabling Mango and Mango actually
being a like a menace to people. Okay, that's like half the content
of the event. How are you getting what are you even getting out
of the event at that point? There's like context to Mango having
won twice that I would either have to like ignore or talk about,
but then ignore, you know? So, to me, it's weird. So,
uh a bit of a bummer there. Uh but thank you you guys cuz uh
thank you w you guys. Who would you ra who would you prefer watching?
This person who wants to take moral centism or like basically
this guy who has no spine I'll say or Nick Fentes who says his
most racist opinions. Uh Nick on like every possible level. Nick
is funny. Lewig's not funny. Okay. Nick has like you to to understand
to watch Nick Fuentes and not be like convinced by him. You have
to actually be like involved in politics. You need to actually
understand something. It's like a challenging watch. Okay. Very
funny guy. Or you can have How is Nick funny? Uh how is Nick
funny?
Completely immune. Yeah. How is Nick funny? Uh that is a difficult
question to answer while on Twitch because I would have to show
you examples. Okay. I would have to show you examples and that's
difficult to do on Twitch. I did think it was very funny last
night when I showed Auggie the last Friday night clip and when
when Fuentes goes Auggie's like I remember when that happened
and then he talked about the Dean versus Fuentes debate and how
that clip happened after.
That was very interesting. Okay. I didn't know I was going to
find a bond with Auggie over our love of how funny Nick Fuentes
is. Okay. I didn't know that was going to be a thing. I didn't
say I was a fan of the politics. I just said the guy's funny.
Okay. No. Stop being so proud. Okay. Well, that's gonna be hard
because I am white. But, um, be ashamed. Um,
outside of that, uh, it it did go really well. Like, I was very
happy
uh, with your reception to it. Uh, that aspect went well, I should
say. Um, like I think we had 75K people in the building. Oh,
on the stream. I was like, what?
So many of you guys prime subbed that we made all our money back
on just subs and ads on Twitch, which is crazy cuz I thought
we were going to lose money on this event to be honest. So, I
appreciate that very much. Uh, six of y'all won switches, which
is nice. I think we did switch. Oh,
that would be a lot of their their uh what do you call it? Their
money. They would have been doing giveaways. 60 switches they
gave away. That's a lot of money, right? 60 switches, I assume.
Switch two. That's like That is a I That's what I hate about
these people. They're like, "We're going to do giveaways and
now I'm going to go say how much money this event cost me." Uh
yeah, 15K. 15K of his hard-earned money. I'm his second favorite
human. And that's like
I might as well be compared to her still. It's No, but like it's
real. Even though I'm his second favorite like Wow. That's tough
when you're not the most loved uh animal parent in a house. Okay,
that's a tough one.
But he's not even just saying not the most love. He's saying
that like basically the dog hates him compared to cutie. Who
the [__] who brags that an animal doesn't like them
that much? That gives us to people who who do trust animal judgement.
Uh that's not what he's trying to do there. He is trying to up
his uh his partner there. He's trying to be like, "Oh, my partner's
so cool." Cuz that's her sitting there, right? He is he is trying
to be like a nice person to her there. That's her sitting there.
She's got the leash human. And that's like and she said he's
saying this dog loves her so much that I'm basically her now.
Oh, so he he's just degrading himself so that she feels like
super special. I think that's kind of what he's doing. I think
he's doing that to like say I think that's what he's doing right
after he asked Chad if he's going to get cancelled for saying
that. Like
I might as well be compared to her. No, but like it's real. Even
though I'm his second favorite, like he loves you so much that
I'm like, "Oh, see. Oh, yeah.
I should have let it keep playing. He just explains. Okay, you're
right. Yeah, he's just trying to he's just trying to be nice.
So, um being nice to your like long-term partner doesn't make
you a I'm sorry. That's not the way the world works. If you see
it that way, you have issues that you need to resolve. Okay.
Prime to cheer the goat. Back to Udachi, you are timed out. You
can come back in a week. Don't you dare untie him out. Stop it.
I didn't actually time him out. Uh I want to though. the twos
for six people, right? I think we did it. I was drunk as hell.
Okay, we did. All right, good. Okay, that's I don't know how
I'm the only one who threw up and Void didn't throw up. I'll
say he's a machine. But yeah, Void is Void is undisputed goat.
I really felt it in the finals, too. He did. Mango Mango not
the goat anymore. Okay, Void the goat. Undisputed. Mango not
the goat touches women when they don't want to when they don't
want it. Okay, Jay, it's actually so much worse than you thought
it was. I don't. Why are you telling me? Don't talk to me. I
just Top Bronson wants No, stop. Top Bronson wants you to know
he uh gave me his prime sub. I told you guys if you donate to
my Twitch, I will see the message and if you let me know that
you want JTock to know, I will tell him. Oh, you guys are so
lucky kick is down right now. Oh, it's not down. Okay, let's
uh let's investigate who exactly is here for people we can raid.
Oh, goes live on Kick Stop. Stop. We're having fun. Uhhuh. We're
having so much fun
on Yingo's keyboard. He threw up on Yingo's keyboard. Is this
on stream? What do you mean? 300 viewers. What? I didn't see
Amaran and Nick is on 40. I kind of see why was the marriage
trauma now. Oh, I see. Did Ledwick just say somebody threw up
on their keyboard at his event and he didn't know about it? Yes.
Yes, it's a drinking event. It literally is a drinking event.
It's like a frat event, right? This is not an event. He's just
finding out. He's just finding out about that now. He's going
over the highlights and he still hasn't found out about the person
who threw up on the keyboard during the event where they were
playing games at computers with keyboards. How is that the thing
that you never find out about until you go live right now? I
don't know. It sounds like somebody said that it happened. It
said that he called everyone at the party and made sure everything
was okay. Not a single person brought up the throwing up on a
keyboard
that I feel like I should watch that party stream. We uh I listen
it might be on it might not be on camera. Who knows? I actually
don't know where it would be but I should I thank um Moon Cake
with T for the five gifted. Thank you very much Moonake with
T. Okay. Awesome. W Moon Moonake with T. Thank you very much.
Thank you Fidi for giving out a sub to my Twitch. It's not live
right now. It's not funny. I I
Oh, what was that sound?
That's gross. What the Do we see it? Do we all see it?
I paused.
What the [__]
What the
It's so gross. What the [__]
Oh, gross. Gross. Gross. I don't give a You're my man's man.
He's still racing. Does he win that race? Oh, he's in first.
Does he win that race? You got to keep watching. I want to know
now, too. Keep watching. Okay. Oh, you're really
Oh, bro. That would have been a level of focus that would have
been incredible. Um, Udaci, thank you for the five gifted on
kick. Okay. Thank you. Uh, I will not time you out. Okay. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Appreciate it, dude. Appreciate it.
appreciate you. Thank you. I knew you like me more than you like.
I knew it. I knew it the whole time. It's okay, Dachi. I am actually
like super appreciative of the subs that you gave me, and I actually
don't need you to give me more subs uh to appreciate what you've
done for me. So, I I'm sorry that JC needed you to give him money
to appreciate you. That must have been really hard. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow. Uh by the way, uh that is another hour on the stream,
guys. It was 45 for that hour. Okay, leave one more at uh Hold
on. No, no, no. I'm going to go to this cuz I think the call
possibly after. Okay, putting more time on stream. Thank you
very much, Udachi and Moon Cake with T. Thank you guys so much
for supporting this. Literally what I wanted to happen. It just
happened the whole the whole event. I'm praying that he's going
to throw up. Also, Cherry is right. I do need money for love.
Okay, that is that is my language of love. Okay, you just give
me money and then I will love you. Okay, thank you. And he does
it one one one beer too late. What's funny is he still would
have won probably. I think he was still far enough up. Do you
do know why those women went on the boat with Did he Yeah. When
when you said those women don't make good decisions because they're
prostitutes. I literally said, "Oh, that reminds me." And then
I shilled. Oh, you did. Sorry. Yeah. I I did not deny that association
whatsoever. That's the short
Keyboard. My bad. Yo, my bad there. Um,
but yeah. Anyway, that's about it for for berio cart. Um, we'll
make it better. The short and sweet. No, the short and sweet
is no. The clips aren't saying me's not invited back to future
Mogamoo's events. Uh he does eventually talk about it. It's like
the next one. We're not making a burial car video and I don't
know if we'll run back another burial cart event. Not even fully
related to this to be honest. I actually had a thought uh like
like oh this is a massive risk as an event like as a concept
that you're all going to get like ludicrously drunk. You all
make like way too much money to get super inebriated live.
Why would you ever risk that? That's like, but isn't that backwards?
Because isn't being a drunk like slobbering mess part of like
the entertainment of some streamers? Like that is what's interesting
about them? It can, but none of the streamers at that party except
maybe Mango, right? So, you probably have to have the right group.
Like, yeah, you go to a kick stream. Okay. You're watching a
kick stream, an Ice Boseidon event where they're partying after.
Yeah, I expect him to be sloppy. Yeah, sure. But not the not
the Lwig stuff. That's not his brand anymore. Oh, true. Okay.
Yeah, I guess that makes sense. That ain't what it is. People
would literally just watch him and those people play Mario Kart
and that's fun. Um
I don't I literally don't understand why people watch Lewig.
I couldn't tell you. I actually don't know. I don't know what's
there. Um that is the one streamer. I understand that he's successful.
I just It's confusing most of the time. I think when the last
time I said this though, I think something happened. I was like,
"Oh, maybe I do get why people watch him a little bit." I don't
know. Well, I know that you always thought that he did good hosting
events. So, I don't know why people watch his stream, but his
events are good. His events turn into content, blah, blah, blah.
Right. I think I understand why he's like good at his job. I
think he is good at understanding what people want, but it's
like he's um it's like he's an algorithm. Like he's he's like
the algorithmic trading of streamers. He just he knows what to
buy and sell. really knows what to change and what to he just
analyzes the market very like uh studiously and figures out what
people kind of want and then he will go to that like transiently.
He doesn't really have there's no him. He doesn't exist. He's
like uh he's basically like operating on chat GPT on what he
should kind of but like I I think that's a talent in and of itself
and I can respect that talent in in a way. Here's Ludwig being
told about the keyboard at the events. My I beat her voice, dude.
My I'm ready, bro. How did they get Pisco at to this event? Void.
Uh, he takes a beer. I'm like, that's crazy. Uh, halfway through
just projectile vomits all over you like
my $700 keyboard. I'm right. I'm trying to rap, guys. Wait, did
that happen? Really? That keyboard got puked on? No way. Did
that really happen, though? I made that really expensive. So,
that was expensive for Adachi to do that one. the the Hassan
laugh. Not cheap. All right, I I'm going to skip forward. This
is uh this is the part where couple more things. They do talk
about mango a little more here. I my food just got here. I'll
be right back. I'm just going to grab my food super quick. Um
I'll show a couple more things.
This is from one of my producers complaining. We did cut off
Mango on alcohol about an hour before stream ended. Three days.
Um but I mean he went into it really drunk and I also personally
apologize. I I look back, it's very cringy now, but I was like
applauding
like him getting new PBS with his blood alcohol, which is like,
you know, super poor taste, especially on hindsight. Obviously,
that wasn't the intention.
What do you mean in hindsight? It's just weird to cheer on alcohol
poisoning.
People die from that. Or did you order just a chicken sandwich?
Is it deep
Uh, no. It's a what do you call it? Um,
Why would you not just make that? Do you not have the components
to make a
I have chicken, but it's Speaking of chicken sandwiches, did
you guys know that Popeye's has some like special dill sauce
uh sandwich? Chicken sandwich. They have like a They have the
regular chicken sandwich. They have like the spicy one. They
have the ghost pepper chicken sandwich. And they have one that
is like dill pickle sauce. I discovered it yesterday and it's
delicious.
Why are you saying cursed in the kitchen? What does that mean?
Okay, I'm cooking, but even I can like get something and put
two pieces in between two pieces of bread. That isn't cooking.
That's just Lego with food. Why are we pretending that 50% of
the time Kelly's been on stream, she hasn't been like eating
peanut butter out of a jar with a peanut butter with a butter
knife. Okay, that happened once. It actually And it lives in
your head. Rentree. This definitely happened way more than once.
No, it only happened once. And it specifically happened because
that was the end of a peanut butter jar and I had a knife and
I wasn't about to make another like piece of cutlery dirty just
to Yeah, it made sense at the time. Mhm. Oh my god. It's called
the pickle glazed chicken sandwich and it is really good.
That's nasty though. Kitty, why is it? It was just the end of
the peanut butter jar and I had a knife. What is nasty about
eating peanut butter? That is confusing. But either way, that's
not cooking. A sandwich is not cooking. You just get a thing
and put it between two pieces of bread.
Oh, also
real quick, real quick. Ry clip. Ral's apparently checking out
Notite content tonight. That's
in Tampa.
Sorry. Is the Are you in the presentation, Kelly? Uh, I trying
to talk when you had stopped talking. Just let her finish her
argument with chat and then explain. No, that that was it. They
were saying you have to cook the chicken where you could just
buy pre-cooked chicken. This is for a sandwich, brothers. What?
Shut up. Okay, we're good. Okay, what is this? Aerodite hate
hour. Uh, I don't know if you guys saw it's not Aerodite hate
hour
hate five minutes. But hey, I can get I don't know if you guys
saw Bridges is done. Bridges is over, but apparently um Aerodite
is going to be working with um the America stuff. What is that?
So, this is like um
if you guys remember that Dean Wither Dean Withers and Parker
were debating and they had this whole thing with UN America where
they left because some black people got insulted by the one woman
who was running it and now and Destiny like talked to her and
apparently was like taking it over. But now Erdite's going to
go work with him on this, which is uh very interesting reforming
that professional association.
Um, is that going to be like the canvasing thing? So, whoever's
in charge of America is about to get fired and Aerodite is going
to take their place even though she has no idea what's supposed
to happen there. You never know. Yeah, you never know. What does
it mean to America? I don't get it. What is that? Uh, so the
purpose of the tour originally was they were going around to
like try to debate Charlie Kirk on college campuses. She's such
she's so weird. She actually just like sat there and was like,
"You guys, I'm not no more political content because I really
I don't want to jeopardize my visa and probably not a good time
to be Canadian here on Visa. Talk about politics." Uh, yes. I'm
just going to do bridges or I'm I'm not going to talk about politics.
Let's just go on podcast and do red pill content and tell men
what to do and save all the young boys. Also, now I'm just gonna
go back to complete politics and now I'm going to travel across
like the United States and tell them everything that they need
to do uh for their country and their political system cuz you
know I've never actually been concerned whatsoever and don't
care. I do find it funny where she says oh like the whole thing
where she's like oh I don't even live here. I I can't vote. I
don't care about this
with the horse for Biden shirts. But um okay also I would just
be I would just be careful. I don't know if she says she's going
I have to hear exactly what she's going to say cuz I don't know.
Okay. To be careful. This could be Riyle can be a little hyperbolic
sometimes with the titling. Okay. We got to watch the whole clip.
We got to see cuz I don't know what she's going to say exactly.
I still stand on everything I said cuz she's went on podcast
and talked about politics like continuously.
She pretended like she was worried. Yeah. Yeah. It's all it's
all true. And listen, it's uh I just don't know why anyone in
this community would think that they're capable of anything.
What a bizarre concept.
Since Wend like having a bunch of arguments at a college campus
are things. He can't even stop his own kid from being a groper.
What good is he going to do for the rest of the
I don't know. But if anyone's going to do it, it's going to be
him and this Canadian woman.
Um yeah, I'm going to be on the tour in Tampa.
Um, trying to say that as Canadian sounding as possible. In Tampa,
I'll be in Tampa on July 12th. Me and Steven. We are powering
up. Where in Tampa? Wow. You know, if you buy a ticket, it will
definitely tell you where. I actually don't know the address.
It's somewhere close by to where Charlie Kirk is having an event.
Um, and so it'll be probably some town in some somewhere downtown
in Tampa. Um, what's going on? Is this like a protester event.
Why are they so close to Charlie Kirk doing his? They do protest.
Yes, that was what America was was doing like protest events
where they go and like try to get to talk to Yeah. try to get
him to talk to somebody who's not like a college student or whatever.
Sean Maloney, thank you for the update and saying me. I guess
that was weird for you to just say you Jtock. That's kind of
odd, but thank you for being here. Shan Maloney, I appreciate
you. Prolific stream Oiler Shawn Maloney. Uh I will I will accept
that you can say that. Okay. when you gift that many subs, you
get to say that. And I I just sit here and I'm like, "Yes, thank
you, sir. Can I have another gifted sub that I'm strongly recommend
to also do like some sort of like meet the streamers after event?"
Cuz it won't just be me. It'll be me and Steven and a couple
of other content creators that are also promoting it. I don't
know who else other than me and Steven to be honest. They're
like Tik Tockers, I think. But, uh, they seem nice enough. Yep.
Um,
think we've rotated out the old unf America tour
cast
uh for slightly more sane ones or at least
if not more sane because they did select me so rut row. But if
not more sane then at least more actually. What was the point
of canceling Bridges if she's still going to work with him what
less than six months later? I I don't know. Or six months later
we'll say. Yeah. I don't Oh, five five months later. interested
in political change and less performative. Okay. And that's that's
all that you
go is right. Sean Maloney with the 25 gifted. Thank you very
much, Sean. Appreciate you. I didn't even get a single one on
Twitch. What the is that? Uh he might not have been here when
you were making your advertisements. Okay, Sean. Thank you very
much for the 25 gifted. Just can't believe I've listened for
13 months. It's been a while. We've been here a while now. I
I'm coming up on two years. I think um the first two year subs
will be about four months from now. I think our first 20 month
sub was two or three days ago. Well, I had time off. So, yeah,
we're making it, guys. We're making it work. Uh I would bet Destiny
actually suggested the bridges ending to her just to get out
of it because he knew it was dog content.
I think you mean the distance, but that's the distance.
No, he hated that podcast. Uh, anyone pretending like he didn't
hate it, he hated it. Oh, he absolutely did. I'm saying when
he was like, "Oh, we should split professionally so you don't
get criticized." That was not to help her out. That was to get
him out of Yeah. Not the ending of it like 5 days ago where it
like actually ends. That was probably just attrition.
And and how the do you at this point in your life with all of
the responsibilities around you because you're like the bread
winner to your family which is like you know this like manchild
that she loves around. How how do you still stick by him knowing
that you just moved across country moved countries right to do
a podcast with him and he's just like yeah you should go my bad.
Well he doesn't listen to the strongest man in the room and that
unfortunately for is just forite destiny. I don't know why she
just doesn't go and like I can't help Emiranth with her horses
or some and just get out of where the [__] is it
possible that she is doing because she did the couple streams.
Anonymous giftter, thank you so much for the five gifted subs
on my Twitch channel that is not live right now. Thank you so
much. My headphones right now. Give me a second. I don't know.
I would just do something else if it were me. I wouldn't I wouldn't
really be giving a about Destiny at this point. It's like Or
just go home. Like come on. Like your old job is probably better
than this. It probably paid better than this. No, it definitely
paid better than this. Right. She wasn't making like a lot. I
have no idea. Living in a termite house. I don't Well, she was
making money from different sources, not just uh the Destiny
LLC or whatever, but also from uh Briana Woo and then from Progressive
Victory. Uh yeah, but when you're like split up between doing
so many things and none of them are paying like super well, you're
just it's impossible to do a good job at all of it, right? It's
like not possible. And so you're just I don't know how people
kind of jobs the content creator hustling
with a lot of different like things that you're dipping into
to try to make enough money. Like I understand why young people
will suffer through it. I don't understand how there's anybody
who is older without like some safety net or something like that
that would ever risk everything for it. Yeah. I don't Yeah. Imagine
taking like a stable career and quitting it to stream. You have
to be Stop. You actually you have like um an education, you have
like work like there's other skills that you have that you can
go do. You know what I mean? Like she's literally she's a mental
health professional that has said insane on the internet. Oh,
true. I don't think she has anything else to go to. Sorry. Go
ahead, Kelly. You also didn't leave your home country. I think
that's significantly cuz you need to make a lot more money in
America for that to be worthwhile or it's just a waste of time.
It's like all of my friends that have got like green cards or
visas from other countries. Um, talk about how much money they
have to make to be like eligible for this. And my friend like
makes millions a year on on fans and even she was like struggling
really hard getting like the green card. It took years and they
after rejections and stuff. I don't know how someone is having
like
a job whilst also trying to like get by in America which is just
like there aren't that many safety nets when it's not your country.
You're just kind of like you better survive or you're like like
I don't know. That sounds awful. Yeah. I I don't know. I think
she's going to go on to talk about what they're going to do with
the American It really matters when you think about it, right?
Also, is this the liberal wing of the tour? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
It turns out that a lot of people on the left, they'll try to
do actual political action with streamers and they'll think because
the loud progressive ones are so loud and so intense about what
they talk about that these people be motivated to do boots on
ground work and then they try to work with them in boots on ground
activities. I'm sorry. I just have to get this off of my chest
real quick. Uh, it's just like sitting on my chest heavy. I haven't
heard anything she said because it's just like weighing my chest
down and I'm going to be such a hater. But I just want to say
go back please. Going back. Didn't Didn't that used to be a choker?
It's like just a necklace now. What are you What are we saying
here? Did that Okay, somebody could a little bit or I don't know
what I'm implying. Is that Is that still a choker?
It's pretty low. It's pretty low. Okay. Well, I think it's cool
that she's gotten past her choker phase.
Jesus Christ. Okay. Uh, that's funny. So, it's okay. I just love
that she's talking about people who are organizing with like
these people being motivated to do boots on ground work and then
they try to work with them in boots on ground activities and
they discover that the only people who actually want to like
make boots on ground change is typically liberals. Wow.
I wonder who supported the the NYC mayor up there upset candidate.
I think that Indians Italians of Asia is it Hassan? Oh my god.
Hassan is not as bad as we thought. Oh my Oh my god. That means
but okay. Wait, wait, hold on. This probably is really unfair.
How many candidates has Destiny supported with his boots on the
ground stuff who have won their elections? I forget. Can we get
like a number on that? Because it's probably really unfair for
me to go like and say, "Hey, Hassan, in like the first time he
like interviews one of these people basically in forever, he
uh that that guy wins the under underdog candidate wins too."
No, I have no idea. I'm literally asking. I literally don't know.
But I I just find it very funny that Waro. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Sure. Sure. Assaf and Waro was in one go. And also that was Sin's
prediction to canvas in that area. So I uh I will say that Sonin
is very politically intelligent. Sin running that operation.
Uh listen, if you're going to be a lazy person who doesn't care
about any politics, doesn't care about real world action at all
and just give money to somebody, you're just going to give money
to them, right? Then I'd appreciate the money going to Sin, right?
Sin. Sin knows what he's doing. He knows how to set stuff up.
He knows how to run stuff or he's at least decent at it. Okay,
Hassan. Can we get Hassan? Hassan's got some money. Can we get
Hassan in touch with Sin? are the Italians of the I'm sorry I
don't want to watch this video. That's unfortunately all the
greatest movements are fundamentally driven by liberals. It's
just progressives like to steal the the valor of it. Okay. And
we'll do volunteer. You can also are the America people not progressives
or hold on. What was the woman's name? Zoe what? Zoe
uh un America. Was it Zoe? Z Cohen Sanchez. Z Cohen Sanchez.
Was she not a progressive? I could have sworn she was a progressive.
Yeah, she was on Bernie Sanders 2016 uh campaign. Does Erdite
literally not do any research into people she's hanging out with
at all? Literally, this person worked with Bernie Sanders. This
person is a
Why Why does Ardite just come out here and totally on progressives?
This is literally a progressive organizer who does work. Why
not just go look at who you're working with before she shows
up and goes, "Progressives don't do anything." You're literally
working with a progressive organizer who set this up. Yeah. Yeah,
just let her read the script. Just let me read the script. Volunteer
with Out of America. Don't know if that means you can go to the
events for free. I have no idea, but possibly somebody should
let me know. I should probably figure out that answer actually.
Um rather than you guys having to tell me. All right, let's see.
Thank you for becoming a member. Hello, Darkness Underneath.
Thank you. I appreciate it. I was asking because he was saying
he was abandoning all his old friends. I assume that included
you, but he never clarified. Well, abandoning all of his old
friends. Is that what happened? Is that Is that how that story
went down? I messaged him and I was like, "Hey, are we good still?"
Cuz last time we talked we were good. And he said, "Yeah, we're
still good." Okay, that was for It must be on just the YouTube.
The YouTubes. Yeah. The worst thing about the chat bots is that
you have to do it in both. Is this not embarrassing for her?
No chatter is telling her he doesn't like you. He abandoned everybody.
He's done with all of his friends. And she's like, "No, no. Well,
I I messaged him. He said we're okay." When I heard him say that
he didn't like his old friends, I had to message him immediately
to make sure we're okay. Listen, when he said he was done with
his old friends, I was very concerned that I wasn't friends with
him anymore. I hope that's embarrassing. You would hope so, but
who knows? Both streams and I feel like Stream Elements is still
not connected to Kick, which is very cringe.
Maybe it is. And I haven't checked though. In fairness, I haven't
I will I got to say to Riyle, okay, the skate gameplay is so
bad that it is actually taking me out of the video. I need you
to find a better side video here. This is just I don't even know
what's happening. Thanks for giving me my roll back. It's working.
I didn't do anything, but You're welcome. Do you ever call yourself
out for being pedantic?
Um,
sometimes. I definitely can be pedantic. Although I suspect when
I'm being pedantic, I'm probably not going to like call myself
out in the moment, but I would agree. I could be pedantic. Um,
I think anybody who's like heavily into the debate space, what
is a whistleblower part? There's a I didn't want to say it. It
is just is the the the thing with the what is a whistleblower
thing is like you could almost forgive the actual oncreen performance,
but then when she's like still doubling down on it later, it's
selection bias that occurs that if you're like a big time debate
bro essentially, there's a decent chance you can be pedantic
sometimes. That wouldn't surprise me. Like I'm pedantic. I've
heard IRI be pedantic before. I've definitely heard um Pisco
be pedantic before. Um I think we all can be and I think it's
definitely a more common debate. Bro, who asked you to name other
people who are bad at this, too? She's just like, "Yeah, I probably
do it." But then here's like a bunch of other people that I think
do it. So, um it's okay. We all like these names, right? You
like these names, bro issue. Um cuz it's it's definitely not
like a left right issue cuz I've heard tons of right-wingers
be super pedantic, too. I think just like when you get really
into debate, being really pedantic can make it feel like you're
about to get a win. Just say, "Yeah, I am pedantic and I don't
care." That's cool. Literally, stop stop saying all of these
other people are pedantic. Just say I am pedantic because I that's
like the people I hang around. That's what I like. You don't
have to like try to make it so that like oh well yeah maybe I
can be pedantic and maybe that's bad. I probably don't call myself
out. But like everybody literally everybody else left, right,
Kisco, I all these other people, they're pedantic too. Um and
you can just get like sidetracked into these like a lot of ped
pedantry will be like words. like we'll just get sidetracked
into fighting about words and you like miss the entire conversation.
What does pedantic mean? Oh no, now I'm panicking. Pedantic means.
Oh god, she's so good at just like taking any criticism. Uh,
it's impressive. It actually is. She said yes. She said yes.
And now she's looking up. What does pedantic mean? Actually,
now I'm panicking.
I'm panicking. Definition that I looked up from here. You guys
can see. Okay, just just so you know what I'm dealing with. Also,
don't I look so orange with this one? I don't like this.
Yes. I don't Okay, I am going to Listen, the misogynist is here
now. Okay, this is actually where the misogyny comes in. Guys,
I know I know that I can be Listen, I I'm not overly pedantic.
Maybe people are pedantic. What does pedantic mean? Uh, why don't
you look at my chest? Hold on. Can I draw attention to my chest
right now, guys? I I Could you please stop asking me questions?
S shirt is you. I have literally I've literally never seen anybody
get a boob job and then literally cover up their chest more than
they did before. I actually don't understand. I just don't understand
on this camera.
Yeah, it is orange.
Wow. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Wow.